it's just a place for this artistic
rendezvous berlin's
I attend National Gallery was one of the
first museums worldwide that showcased
works by the Impressionists and
Expressionists at the end of the 19th
century
this exhibition brings them together
like seldom before the curators had
plenty to choose from and 160 works are
on display matter who you look at there
was an emphasis on the idea of artistic
freedom and seeing the big picture
radically expanding art once more in
photo contests Incans this was the face
of rebellion at the end of the 19th
century Impressionists such as Monet
suddenly painted outdoors in nature at
the start of the 20th century
Expressionists began leaving their mark
with colorful luminous and clear lines
they developed a bold new visual
language I think it's the freedom in
these works that speaks and moves us
today it's the lights the colors the
rendering of nature I think it's a lot
of pictures from a time that was
essential in shaping out your heart
egrets had often a few foremast
capabilities the exhibition focuses on
collective scenes of life before World
War one in big cities during the day and
at night
pleasure-seeking song-and-dance were
prime elements in the work of
expressionist ants Ludvig kishna who
ventures a peak below the waist the show
is an impressive encounter between famed
works of both styles and it runs through
September in Berlin